[Musik]
vielleicht ein jahr zuschauer ist
insofern gut einzusetzen weil sie wenn
dick leistungsstark und im hochgebirge
gut einzusetzen ist hier in diesem fall
in kärnten hochwassereinsatz setzen wir
flughelfer aus die die masten für die
stromversorgung wieder herrichten und
machten verbindungs flüge
beziehungsweise versorgungsflüge die
bevölkerung der abgeschnitten ist
[Musik]
insgesamt im einsatz haben wir bisher
zusätzlich zu den 60er jahren auch noch
20 mann der fliegerkräfte gehabt wir
werden sehen auch in das hochwasser
zurück geht welche schäden dann noch zu
tage treten und wo das österreichische
bundesheer hier noch unterstützen kann
[Musik]